Hello everybody!
Hello!
Hi!
Welcome to singing lessons!
I'm going to be getting...
Yeah, I'm going to be getting sing lessons from USAN because
we have a concert together soon.
When is it?
When is the concert?
Uh, August 4th.
Oh my god, that's really close.
That sounds like...
like in oh my god it's like like in a week listen yeah
listen to it's a week in two days i didn't even realize it
was that close guys even though the concert isn't like a
week in two days i'm gonna get my singing lessons now yeah
you did you said you think i had enough time i mean more you
practice you will be a better singer so you know this is
gonna be my only practice guys and then I'll because I know
you son is gonna teach me so well that I only need one
practice right okay okay okay let me defend myself real
quick okay so wait well you defend yourself you're a great
teacher aren't you no okay so you know what I'm what I'm
gonna be shut up what I'm gonna be sharing right now it's
not a hundred percent recommended okay wait what no no no no
it doesn't mean like it I mean, like, it's not dangerous at
all, okay?
I mean, I can't guarantee even you follow this.
You gotta be a good singer or whatever because everyone have
their own method, okay?
But you're such a great singer.
You should be able to transfer your skills to me.
Okay, you say that, okay?
You say that, you say that.
Yeah, you say that.
Wait, was, I don't listen to your song.
It was like, whoa.
Now you did that.
Now you did that by yourself.
Okay, hope you don't get a regret for that.
I hope you won't regret for that.
Okay, okay.
But I tell you, my vocal listen is extreme.
It's extreme.
So does that mean I'll be like a really good singer after
you're done?
I thought you want to be a good singer.
I mean, yeah, yeah.
What is the reason you're asking me to do the vocal listen?
Yeah, yeah.
Because you're going to give me, I'm going to be able to
sing just like you.
you after this lesson is over, right?
Uh...
Maybe you need to practice like a 10, 10, not 10 years or
like 10 years?
I don't have that much time!
Oh, please don't underestimate my singing skill!
You don't know how much you meant for this!
But like, the food!
I want it now!
I don't want it Okay, so after this, after this, as an
exchange, you have to give me the gaming lesson They're not
playing a stream.
You gotta be responsible.
My gaming is good.
Oh, my gaming technique.
It's all good.
Gaming is a talent.
It's not you can't just become a gamer.
You have to be born like a game you have to be born a gamer
There's no such thing as gaming lessons, but there's singing
lessons it's strange okay i'll try my best to make you a
good singer after this so one day you have to make me an
apex legend well like if you're not born with it then i
don't know if i can like you have to be i told you you have
to be born a gamer you saw me oh oh oh that it's not about
you did you born did you born a singer as well no no no i
was born a gamer No, that's why there's singing lessons.
There's no gaming lessons.
There's singing lessons So what is the whole point of this
lesson?
Because you're gonna teach me how to sing Gaming and singing
is very different.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but okay Whatever let's do the warm-up.
All right before we warm up How's the volume guys?
I don't know if my sound guy is on today.
So how's the volume chat?
You know what my other mod my other mod you're gonna be
sound guy for now because i don't know if the actor but the
if our sound guy is here today you guys gotta be the sound
tech guys oh okay never mind it never mind i have one of my
sound guys here the discord sound guy oh wait my other sound
guys also here the two sound guys sound keeper let's go yeah
all right all right can you say something you son just real
quick scream for me yell for me Oh,
God, okay.
Whoa, what did you say?
What did you say?
I just speak the random, not on the random stuff in Korean.
All right, we're ready.
What's my first lesson?
Okay, so we're going to be doing the warm-up.
Okay.
But I don't like waiting you.
So what you have to do is just follow exactly what I'm
doing.
Okay.
chat you're gonna watch her please watch her that she's not
slacking out yeah i'm not slacking i'm a hard worker yeah
okay we'll see that we'll see that okay with exceptions with
exceptions okay i'm gonna change the discord uh setting real
quick okay try mute myself uh yeah okay i'm gonna just start
like just everything just by my own timing so just follow me
okay if you're following oh my god i don't i don't i don't
we don't hear you hear you what
did i do what did i do now
you hear me right yeah yeah yeah we can hear you now you
when you played that we just stopped hearing you we couldn't
hear you and you played it whenever you were trying to play
oh we don't hear you anymore you don't hear you anymore oh
shit wait i'll put device how about this that way oh my god
wait oh my god sorry do you hear me yeah i can hear you now
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait Can I play some random music?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's okay I'm indie, it doesn't
matter
Do you hear the music?
No Do you?
No, no, no Word and work Oh, we don't hear you anymore I
hear myself I hear myself Hey girl girl
Looking now what the what the fuck is happening here?
on it I hear you again.
I hear you again.
It's time.
Well, well, oh, oh
We don't hear you we don't hear you I hear myself though.
I hear myself though.
Hey girl.
Hey, girl Okay, so now I am at the voice setting now on the
discord right okay i'm a boomer you're gonna carry me okay
it's all right it's okay guys today is not also technical
lessons day too okay so for the voice setting input devices
to chat mic now and i believe we have to use the the
broadcast stream mix right yeah but we don't hear you we
don't hear you we i hear me i hear me maybe your input mic
is not on the broadcast
we're still we're still we still hear me only
shit how do i do that i'm sorry guys it's okay guys It's
tech support.
I'm not streaming through my setup, okay?
So, yeah.
You know, gotta be patient for that.
We're gonna fiddle around.
No, I just checked it.
It's actually a broadcast stream mix.
Yeah, but I think your mic isn't attached to your broadcast
stream mix.
It could be separated.
You can check it.
If it's separated.
Is the setup used Go XLR?
Go XLR?
I don't know if you're talking.
Do you?
Are you?
Hello?
I don't hear me now, though, at least.
Dude, you hear me now, right?
Yeah, yeah, I hear you now.
Did you...
Do you...
Is that set up?
Go XLR?
Um...
You know what, dokey?
Fuck that.
We're gonna...
Okay!
Okay, I'm gonna send you the link.
Okay.
I'm gonna send you the link, okay.
And you're gonna do that.
You don't have to, you know, show this video on your stream,
but, you know, just sing along this one.
It's in Japanese, but just follow the sound.
Okay, okay, I'll play.
You're gonna play it too, right?
So we're both listening to it at the same time.
Are you sure about that?
Are you sure you want to do that?
I don't know what I'm doing.
What about Emma?
Okay, okay, okay, sure, sure.
I'm gonna be doing that too.
Okay, okay, okay, I'll do a cat.
and i'll play at the same time okay ready yeah three two one
okay oh welcome here i don't i don't know it's no more it's
gonna be fun okay the ripro ripro ripro okay
longer longer longer long longer make it long
Do it longer, longer, longer.
Have fun.
All right, ready?
One, two, three, four.
You're climbing up the mountain.
Okay.
I don't want to climb the mountain.
Yeah?
How do you feel?
I don't want to climb the mountain.
Come on, it's a warm-up.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, humming.
Don't laugh, don't laugh.
You're laughing.
I'm driving to my back.
That's so high.
Up and up and up and down there.
Up and up and up.
Okay, good.
Okay, now you just follow the sound you hear, okay?
A-E-U.
oh
yeah Meow!
Meow!
The big cat!
Your cat!
Meow!
Okay, nice.
Okay, now you're a dog.
Ooh!
Oh!
Uh...
Five time.
Okay, second time!
Uh...
Higher!
Ooh!
Uh...
Oh, three times.
Oh, we get higher, too.
Okay, two more time.
Last time.
Come on, you got this.
Three times, but the short one, okay?
Oh.
Okay, we're done.
We're done.
Okay, stop there.
Stop there.
That was hard.
That was really hard.
That was a warm up.
Come on.
You want to be the real singer after this stream, right?
That was so hard.
Why do you think it's gonna be easy?
Why did you thought it's gonna be easy?
Come on.
I thought it was gonna be easy.
Singing's never easy.
Singing's not easy.
Even though you're good at singing, it doesn't guarantee you
to make you make you famous as well.
Singing here, the music industry is fucked up.
Why are you crying?
But I want to be a good singer now.
Okay, everybody, thanks for coming.
Okay, Doki gave up for the warm-up round.
No, I didn't give up.
I just think, I just think if you are an amazing teacher,
you can make me a great singer in one lesson.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
ego you can fill up my ego because you're an amazing singer
and um you're so talented so that means you can easily make
other people just as talented but not as talented as you
just a little bit less talented than you but still just as
talented okay i'm not smart enough to say to understand what
do you actually say but well okay um I think the good
singer, they know how to sing with no tension to your
throat.
Was there tension on my throat?
Yeah, like, have you ever like felt like when you're
singing, like your throat, your vocal cord like felt so
tired will like, you know, start feeling itchy or something.
Yeah, but I'm always tired, so look.
Okay, okay, so when you when you sang Disney song, yeah?
Yeah.
did you feel any like tension to your throat or like any
stress or did you ever had like any throat pain before well
not from singing maybe from just talk okay fuck that fuck
that okay so this this training yeah this training will
actually teach you how to release your tension from your
throat the discord i send you video right yeah yeah yeah and
there is the chat says uh vocal ventilation vocal
ventilation yeah vocal vent i see vibrato oh vocal expand
expansion no the expansion ventilation there's your
ventilation i sent it that no you did it i know i don't you
didn't give me ventilation you got vibrato pitch accuracy
wait wait wait wait a moment i think i sent it already wait
oh but you never you didn't match it you didn't give me a
word for it oh i did i did i did hold a moment i would just
send you the i will just send you now you know because i'm a
good teacher you're such a good teacher i'm awesome teacher
so hold a moment Choto, choto, choto moment.
Choto, choto, choto, choto.
Choto, choto, choto.
I'm choto-ing.
Choto-ing?
Yeah.
It's awesome.
Don't you think it's awesome?
Like, every time I'm doing a vocal lesson, I mean, it's
definitely my first time doing a vocal lesson.
Yeah!
I can tell.
It's 100% my first time, you know, giving someone a vocal
lesson.
Yeah, every time I am preparing the video for them, so they
can just follow the note along the piano line that I play.
Yeah, because we have a piano right here!
Yeah!
That's why we have piano here!
Okay.
Can you play that?
Yeah, okay.
Mm-hmm.
I'm...
I'm waiting for notes to come out.
Mm-hmm.
Oh!
I hear it.
So you hear...
It's...
It's getting weak to stronger, right?
Yeah.
So...
So when you heard the sound, I want you to...
Emphasize the sound, like every time you say.
But from now, I want you to tongue out.
Uh...
I don't have a tongue my tongue muscles doesn't go that far
I have a very because I have a very short tongue you song so
like your tongue is super long that's why it comes out of
your mouth my tongue is super short so it doesn't it doesn't
no I don't have a long enough tongue your tongue is like
super long like a lizard it's not
Super short.
Nice tongue is super.
Fuck that.
Anyway.
I'm sorry Dragoon, but you know, I, I, you know, at least
you get to hear the sound.
So just, just appreciate me already.
So do it like, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Then make it louder.
Yeah.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, like that.
Four.
the piano yeah follow the piano okay that's what do you do
okay hang out okay okay uh uh uh okay
don't make okay okay i'm serious i'm serious don't make it a
joke yeah this is a serious listen i'm trying i'm trying my
best i'm trying to let you get a Grammy You know!
You think I can get a Grammy?
Uh...
No, not from your...
From a diaphragm!
Uh...
Don't give up on me!
Oh, no, my tongue touched the mic.
That's so gross.
Okay, I think you have to tongue out more.
You know, like, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Ah,
the video's over.
Ah, ah, okay.
is the is the video volume okay
why are you laughing you said you're laughing this is not
fair why can't the teacher laugh at me the teacher should
not be not to laugh at their students that's gonna tell you
something i'm sorry dokey there is no such a lesson exists
like this i just made it up what you made of this lesson
that's fucked up that's fucked up oh my god seriously i hope
you i hope your live 2d uh i hope your live 2d creators
watching this so you know i i hope they're gonna they're
gonna get you a new toggle I hope I never get a longer
tongue.
I hope my tongue remains short forever.
Come on, we need your tongue out.
No!
I'm not going to use...
I'm not going to use my tongue.
What is it for?
It's not used for it.
Tongue, it's pretty useful.
Like, hey, Nuki, look at me.
Look at me.
Huh?
Yeah.
What?
what the fuck like what's in use what you don't you don't
feel irritated i was counting on you well anyway okay um
joke aside i say that this i just made up this training
right yeah um actually the real professional singer they
also do a lot of tongue trainings too because it helps to
improve your pronunciations uh-huh and also the breast
control so i recommend you doing this actually oh okay yeah
i made it up but it still work okay oh oh so it's it's still
actually training me it's uh yeah i was actually training
you oh my god i knew it i knew you would at the same time oh
okay no oh okay
it's like that movie you know that movie about that drummer
guy where like the teacher's super harsh on him but then
it's because he only wants him to improve more Is that it?
Is that what you're trying to do?
You're making fun of me.
Oh No, I'm just trying to think about like how to make it as
a content.
That's all
Okay You're not trying to make me a better you're not trying
to make me a stronger singer.
I see I see That was the vocal ventilation, basically
focusing on how to relax your throat and also, you know,
release any tension from your throat.
And after that, let's move on to vibrato.
Okay.
You know what vibrato is?
Vibrato?
No.
Vibrato.
What is it?
For example.
Okay.
Ponyo, right?
Yeah.
Ponyo, ponyo, ponyo.
Whoa.
This is a vibrato.
But if I put the vibrato, Oh my god.
I can't do that.
That one, that one.
You hear the wave, right?
That's the vibrato.
Yeah.
yeah yeah you want to do that sure i'll try i don't think i
don't know if i can okay so if you're able to do vibrato
your singing's gonna sound slightly better okay oh just
slightly just a little bit a lot better a lot better yeah
how about that a lot better yeah that's good all right okay
so i also send you the video there right yeah yeah yeah i
see it oh i hear it okay yeah i hear it okay
yeah so uh there was like a shake my wave there so focus on
doing that that one yeah shake it I can't do that's all
fresh Do you watch Joe's
Joe's Joe's You're sharks Yeah yeah yeah You are a Same da
yo yeah You are a Same
Okay Are you ready to Are you ready to do that with a
pianoscope?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's do that.
Do I push play?
Me?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, so people can hear you playing the sound, right?
Yeah.
So people will know that you're not slacking out the song.
Uh.
Ah!
You can say another thing too.
Dragon, dragon, dragon, dragon, dragon, dragon!
Did I do it?
Yeah.
Keep going, keep going.
Oh, it stopped.
It ended.
Mustafa did I did I oh wait oh I no no I I pressed the wrong
button
Staccato okay
Shake your voices, shake it, shake it, shake it, shake it,
shake it, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
Oh You're doing awesome
Uh...
Yay!
I did it.
Did you follow the piano scale actually?
Yeah!
What do you mean?
It's getting higher.
The notes are getting higher, but your sound, your notes is
like constantly like same key.
What?
Oh, you did it well!
No, no, no, no, no!
Very good!
A plus!
I didn't know.
I thought I was singing.
So good.
Okay, do you want to drink some water?
Okay.
I'm doing my best.
You were doing.
Of course.
Baby, you're doing okay.
I need positive reinforcement.
The more you compliment me, the better I'll do.
You can expect that from me.
Yeah.
Really?
You can expect that from me.
Yeah, how are you going to be positive right now?
You're not being very positive, so that makes me sad.
I'm super positive.
You know, I see only the improvement from here, you know.
I only see the potentials.
I only see a lot of potential of improving from here.
You know what I mean?
From here, so I wasn't improving before.
Okay, now you're probably at the lowest bottom.
But, you know, not me, you have a lot of sign of him.
have a sign of improvement you know what i mean i'd be like
one if this is not a compliment i don't know what it is you
told me i'm
not think about it think about it okay think about it if
you're at the lowest bottom you're not going any lower you
know you're not going any lower than that you're not gonna
fail from that but i'm still at the bottom i'm still at the
bottom you know what
Children are at the bottom.
But you're comparing me to a child.
Are children better singers than me?
Oh, you can't say anything because you have to be positive.
That's fucked up.
You don't say anything because you have to be positive.
That is so fucked up.
It's because you just twist anything I say.
You just like, oh my God.
Like, oh, I don't know.
Dragun!
It's not my fault!
What's not my fault?
I don't know, man.
Oh, God.
Okay, so that was the...
What's next in the singing lesson?
What do you have next?
Pitch accuracy.
Oh, maybe I'll be good at that.
So, okay, so good singing.
like they don't need mix oh not like me
are you confident that you can hit every note like correctly
all the time because uh when you're singing in live uh
there's no mixer there's no there's you know auto tune or
there's nobody who can actually collect your tune and
pitches you know so the good singer they always have to sing
in the right pitch yeah so the pitch accuracy practice is
really necessary and it's really important for them okay so
that's not me basically you just started yeah yeah like
nobody's before until today so all i can do is improve
nobody's nobody's good from the beginning yeah yeah yeah not
even you yeah exactly yeah exactly so yours you sang just
like so your singing was just like mine
you son my god did i just got insulted You literally said
nobody is singing.
Are you trying to sing?
Why are you trying to sing about my singing?
What are you trying to sing about my singing?
What do you mean something?
Okay, you can say that.
You can say that if you're going to just stop singing Disney
or Jubilee and just sing the other song.
I've been done.
The songs are so hard.
The other song.
it is but okay they're also in japanese i can't sing okay uh
you can just say anything i can hear it when you did that
yeah me um it's because i'm playing through my ipad you know
oh yeah because i have i have keyboard on my ipad okay oh
okay i was gonna say i could hear it I don't want to just...
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
That's what you do.
Okay, I'll show you now.
me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me,
me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me,
can't be anything.
I want you to do that with the video I sent you.
Okay.
You can just say anything.
I'll play it now.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
No, no, no, no.
Papa Papa Papa Papa Papa Wow Wow Wow Wow Wow Focus on
hitting the right pitch Oh Oh Oh
Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh
Wow Wow wow wow Wow
Mmm Mmm Mmm Mmm Mmm Mmm
Not bad to be honest
Okay, focus on hitting the right pitch.
That's out of tune.
Mm.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, yeah!
Good!
Not bad, actually.
See, I can have good pitch!
Yeah!
This practice, uh, you should focus on hitting the right
pitch.
So you know, uh, it's not anything about, like, training.
your, you know, vocal muscle or not like that.
It's more like training your music sense.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Did I explain?
I thought I was a good teacher.
I thought I explained pretty well.
You are a good teacher.
or is it the is it the language value though even though i
improve my english this much i can even transfer the right
message to someone that i really need holy shit holy shit
okay drink uh drink water yeah okay yay water time you are
you son thank you you're the best man okay so far how do you
feel i feel great i think i can be like i think i'm like
really talented
i think i'm like a natural oh yeah you gotta be scared you
son i'm gonna overtake you soon in like two days oh my gosh
i someone destroy her please someone do that
positive reinforcement I thought I was supposed to have
positive reinforcement Okay so you say that You want to take
over My singing skill My strength Would you be happy Because
that meant you like taught me to be better than you Wouldn't
you be proud of that Just try to The student overtakes the
teacher That's like a classic throw Try me Try me not now
I'm still a student.
And maybe in two days.
Maybe next week on your concert.
That's like...
That's so messed up on your own concert.
Okay.
How about...
Okay, you can prove me that by in the next lesson.
Okay, it's the next lesson.
That's the vocal expansion.
Vocal expansion?
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
My string!
That I think!
Yes.
Okay, in my opinion, my string is the vocal range.
Okay.
So that's gonna be my string too, right?
Yeah, I mean, try that.
Try that.
Okay.
I'm just gonna show you how I do that, okay?
That's the piano sound you hear.
Ah.
It's a little bit risky to use the voice.
So rip-roll.
Rip-roll.
And do it as long as possible.
Whoa.
Easy.
Yeah.
Easy, right?
So you make it look so easy.
Of course.
Because it's easy for me.
So that means you're going to be easy for me too.
Yeah.
Okay.
I got this.
Yeah.
And don't stop that.
Okay.
Just keep going as much as possible.
Vibra.
Switch.
Good, good, good,
good.
Yeah, you forgot to switch that.
Don't stop that.
Keep going.
Higher, higher.
I'm not gonna stop her.
I'm not gonna stop.
I can do this to everything.
Are you tired?
Yeah!
You're tired?
No, I'm not stopping her.
Okay.
Good on, guys.
RR THERE RR RR RR RR RR RR
RR RR RR RR
did you finish it i think you can stop that already it's i i
start feeling sorry because you know i kind of feel like i'm
publicly blank i mean like you know yeah i don't want to be
cancelled anymore you know yeah i just want to i i gotta i
gotta defend myself now why okay um that's the vocal
expansion yeah oh my god you didn't even do all the high
notes i can do it i'm doing almost everything do it do it
try it doing right now
higher like that oh shit that's high no no it's it's not
that high i can i can higher mode it's just i can i'm just a
bit tired oh oh you're tired okay you are tired you have
concert prep yeah yeah well anyway yeah that was the basic
practice then i bet uh this is pretty easy for everyone to
follow okay you can really underestimate the ripples as well
uh yeah this one gives you a breast control then you will
notice that you will get like enough stamina to sing the
entire song because some people they can sing just you know
finish singing just one single song because it makes them so
tired.
Yeah.
So for those people I really want all of them to consider
doing the lip rolls because this really helps.
Yeah I'm already tired.
I mean Yeah, vocal training is something you shouldn't
really do like more than an hour.
You know, if you do vocal training like at 40 minutes, maybe
like a three times a week, that should be good enough.
Three.
Oh, three times a week.
I thought you said three times a day.
Okay.
No, don't do that.
Three times a week.
You don't want to destroy your throat, you know.
Yeah, I don't.
Your vocal code is pretty sensitive.
So it's the reason why I don't recommend the streamers to,
you know, stream every day because I changed every day this
week.
But I did it.
How many hours?
I don't know.
It'd be two to three hours.
Two to three hours should be fine.
But let's say if you're streaming more than five hours,
that's pretty concerning.
I don't recommend doing that.
Yeah, that's not good, guys.
Remember to rest your vocal cords.
Yeah.
Your vocal cord is really sensitive.
Yeah, you don't want to get surgery on your vocal cords.
It's like a paper, guys.
Then if it's a chordal or something, it wouldn't be back.
It wouldn't be the same anymore.
So be really careful.
That's why I don't sing every day.
Because I care about my vocal cords.
And you can't beat me on the stage anymore.
Okay, you accepted that.
No, I still have a week and two days.
Yeah.
I still have a week in two days.
Guys, do you guys know?
Okay, where this?
Whoa, that's a big picture, okay?
You said you're trying.
Guys!
That's the fuck!
Why?
That's my concert!
There's no image of me!
Guys!
Look, I'm gonna have a concert!
That's my concert!
Guys, you can go see me at Trails of Flames.
Trails of Flames.
Guys, I'm gonna be in Hong Kong.
I can't believe the concert organizer.
They actually made this poster.
And there's no image of me at all.
No image.
Not even my name is that!
Oh my god!
with my special guest who you saw okay here's the actual
concert there you go so anyway i'll put it on okay you saw
why don't you talk about your concert
check my music video that's not a that's not a concept okay
so why is it one man live what about me okay that should be
a two man live i mean i'm promoting myself by the i deserve
this i deserve promoting myself okay whoa okay everyone uh
hello the trail of flame it's my uh first mini world tour so
i'm gonna be the first stuff gonna be hong kong and then
taipei and after that stopping the last stop gonna be tokyo
and it's a full band live performance with my band member
and it's my official return on stage because uh there
another reason why i become vtuber is that uh i start having
uh performance anxiety and i was not able to sing in front
of people but this time i am officially uh returning on the
stage.
So if you guys are going to be there, that means a lot.
And there's going to be, excuse me.
Okay.
What?
That's my concert.
Why?
What did I do?
Well, there's no only singing.
This is going to be like a lot of, you know, surprises and
there's gonna be uh the concert organizer they're trying
their best to you know prep something for not only for my
fan also for you know dorcas fan for dragons so if you guys
are in hong kong and if you guys are interested we'll meet
there okay and there's also live viewing in uh south korea
as well yeah yeah yeah the v square yeah the v square
uh people from hong kong and also people from so we'll meet
there okay yes thank you i'm super excited i you guys are
gonna be so excited about the the songs songs me and you
song picked for our two men live uh sure sure that's why
that's why you saw us teaching me how to Do you want to
finish off last one?
Just like last one?
Last one?
Before we're going to be wrapping up.
What do you mean by last one?
Do you remember?
I send you the instrumental.
Then I want you to do the rip roll.
Oh.
With an entire instrumental.
What is this?
I think I sent you maybe the first message of today.
I think.
Oh!
Do you want to do that?
But if you're tired, I'm not forcing you to do that.
Okay.
I can't do it.
Guys, watch this.
It's gonna be so cool.
Yay!
Oh, shit!
That's so... I'm sorry.
That was really loud.
You're never gonna be a musician.
Oh,
hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey.
Oh, hey.
He go.
What?
Tora-in.
Oh, it's a Cantonese song.
Oh!
Is that how you call?
Yeah!
Oh!
Doraemon.
Or Ding Dong!
Ding Dong!
You watch my tala now.
That's how I'm called, Doraemon.
Ding Dong Leila!
Ding dong
Do you know like There's like a meme song It's like You
touch my ta-la-la What?
Don't you say that to dole-a-mong No, no, no, this is ding
dong No, not ding dong No, don't ruin Ding Dong!
Oh, okay, you know that song, right?
Oh, you know that song, right?
I bet everyone know that song.
You guys know what I'm talking about, right?
Ooh, you touched my ta-la-la.
My ta-la!
It's what we call Daemon!
That's what we call, we call Lim Ding Dong!
We used to call him that.
What was the ding dong stumps for?
Is it like a sound of the bell?
It's like, you know, the bell.
Yeah, it's a bell.
It's like, oh, don't say that about him!
Bell!
Yeah, you know the bell he has on his collar?
So it goes ding dong.
Yeah.
So that's all I call him.
Bones?
No!
I'm done with the ding dong joke.
no okay seriously uh good job you have done like a you know
16 minutes uh vocal training yeah which is quite a lot is
that a lot that's that's actually a lot yeah actually we do
around like 40 minutes training that's the normal ring yeah
wait i mean you should say wait wow You should sing
Doraemon.
What does it sound like when you sing Doraemon?
Do you want me to sing Akapera?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
.
We're backing vocals.
Oh,
that's a dream, Oh my god!
Yay!
Now do Disney.
Release me.
Do Disney!
Wait, what's the Disney song that you know?
Do you know any Disney songs?
A lot of Disney songs.
Of course I know a lot of Disney songs.
Thanks everyone!
Thanks for having me here!
I'm so honored!
Being here, then I'm so happy that Dockies, you know, be
gonna be my first guest for my world tour.
That means a lot to me.
So thank you so much for joining this.
And thank you so much for the background team.
I really appreciate that.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for teaching me how to sing, your son.
I had a great time for my singing lessons.
I learned so much today.
What?
I did.
I did learn a lot.
yeah at least at least i tried my best i'm totally gonna do
this lesson again for sure
sure sure
yeah thank you again you sound for the same lessons i had a
great time so yeah check out the
I'm going to be a special guest there in August 4th.
Yes, I know that.
Yes.
Did you say?
In August 4th in Hong Kong.
So I'm really, really excited.
And today you have something at ACGHK, right?
Oh yeah.
I'm going to be showing up on the ACGHK main panel.
And I'm going to have a special guest, Shoto.
uh anyone of you there in hong kong uh we will meet there uh
how do i say that uh lie lie lie i want to say come oh lay
lay lay lay lay lay lay lay lay lay lay i have a free checky
there for all of you guys it's a present so yeah it's a free
stage so i'm gonna be at acghk too but Yes.
Yes.
Wow.
It's as if we planned this to stay together at the end.
But I will be at ACGHK as well.
Right.
Let's go.
I also have merch there too.
Exclusive ACGHK merch that it'll be there for all the days,
all five days.
So yeah.
But tomorrow I'll be there for a panel as well.
And it'll be at booth F for 36.
and uh and you can leave gifts and letters could you guys
can you guys leave gifts and letters to you you son as well
uh are you guys accepting gifts as well I don't think we're
doing this this time but I'm accepting that at the concert
venue guys yeah I'm accepting gifts and letters at ACGHK but
you have to give it put at the booth F36 but I'll also be in
Singapore today well you sons in I'll be at Singapore.
Yes, where?
How many conventions did you showed up already?
Oh, it's a lot.
It's like a horror convention, like convention every, like I
don't know, every month.
It's a world tour.
Yeah, every month I think I have like a convention, I think.
I'll be at, because I want to meet all my fans.
I want to meet all my dragoons around the world.
Actually, that's ambitious, but please do take care of
yourself.
I'm trying.
I'm trying my best But yes, I'll be at Anime Festival Anime
Festival Asia In Singapore today I think my panel is like in
three hours So like if you're watching this on your phone
right now Or on your PC Waiting for my I'll be there in
three hours guys
I think I should have Yeah, I have like merch there too I
have like a t-shirt or something At Anime Festival Asia They
guys want to get it.
Let me grab the PNG.
I didn't save it because I'm not a professional.
Yeah!
So yeah.
I have stuff there too.
I'm tired.
You saw.
Come on.
It's in three hours.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm going to be singing in this.
there and oh yes i'll be singing one song disney oh i don't
know it's gonna be a surprise disney disney i'm not gonna
say disney just because you out of spite out of spite i
won't say disney i mean dry moon is at least something which
is not disney or jibli i'm kind of proud of that i sang like
one jibli song and then Buddy Chris Guys, I actually force
Doki to sing pocket pocket dance.
Okay You're gonna appreciate me for that
It's like such an easy song and I already forgot the lyrics
like you know like the first time when I send you the video
link Yeah, like you know, oh, I can't sing this one.
I thought it was in Japanese for some reason.
I don't know I just thought it was in Japanese It's a cute,
cute, Japanese sounding English.
Hey, boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie,
boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie,
boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie, boogie, boon, boon.
I knew that this song's going to fit you pretty well, so,
yeah.
Do you ever remember the song?
Yeah, proud of you.
I don't remember those lyrics, so I remember the first
verse.
Hey, boogie, boogie, boogie, boon, boon, boon.
Let's go, boogie, boony, boon, boon, boon.
Well, you sing one line.
I sing, I sing three lines.
Be my buddy.
Crap, crap, crap.
You forgot the lyrics, too!
I do remember that!
I just, I do, I memorize everything.
Come on.
You literally was like, crap, crap, crap.
You already forgot the lyrics!
It's actually clap, clap, clap.
Oh, clap, clap, clap.
Be my buddy, clap, clap, clap.
Yeah.
And then what?
my body get up and dance yeah see choose it to the body and
then move your move your body let's enjoy I don't remember
and get closer day by day yeah okay do you still want to
challenge me do you still want to challenge me what's okay
sing the Pokemon song from memory why is this am I allowed
to sing in the Japanese version.
No, English.
I don't know that.
I didn't grew up.
I didn't grow up walking Pokemon in English.
You said you remember every song you say.
I can only sing the Japanese one, not the English one.
I can sing Digimon song, though.
That's Butterfly.
Yeah, that's Butterfly.
I can sing everything.
I can't even memorize everything.
You sing it during Anime Expo.
That's cheating!
It's still fresh in your mind.
You're like froze.
Are you serious?
Oh, there you are.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm thinking.
What's the song that I know?
I think I can just sing everything that you know.
Except for Pokemon.
Except for the English Pokemon song.
You can't sing that.
Oh, biggest streamer.
Nice.
That's a good idea.
I love the biggest streamer.
Teamers.
Digimon Timus.
Yeah.
That's one of the best Digimon sleeves.
Is that one?
Yeah, that one.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, sing toxic.
Be the biggest, biggest dreamer.
Sing toxic.
Toxic.
You don't even know toxic!
You don't even know the lyrics are toxic.
You stupid, you fucking bitch.
You don't even know the lyrics for toxic.
You're not.
You fucking bitch.
I know it's a Brittany Spears.
Come on guys.
You don't even know the lyrics so technically you don't know
every song lyric you've ever listened to.
You don't know everything Bitch.
You bitch.
There's no you bitch.
There's no you bitch in toxic.
Where are you getting that from?
That's all I know.
Where the fuck did you get the bitch from?
You bitch.
What?
That's what I know.
Am I correct or wrong?
No, there's no bitch in there.
You're toxic.
I'm slipping under.
That's the lyric.
Where did you get bitch from?
But yeah, I remember it was something you, right?
Then...
Yeah.
So many.
What?
That's fucked up.
Yeah, I mean, we don't count that.
That's not.
This is not positive reinforcement.
This is.
Now I'll never get better at singing because my teacher
isn't positive.
My teacher called me a bitch.
Now I'll quit singing forever.
Two didn't.
student student yeah that's me don't don't don't mix up
don't make don't mix up relics and also my word don't mix up
your private and also the relics it's not it's not even
though even okay even though i call you bitch you're not
gonna make you bitch i mean the wasn't even in the lyrics
the real lyrics or do you want to be a no i'll cry yeah you
don't want to be a right no because that's what you are then
just don't take my word seriously i'm just saying but even
though i call you a you're not gonna make you yeah yeah yeah
yeah right yeah right what the fuck is this conversation
they don't they didn't know they didn't know what i just
told them
yay oh i'm okay i'll i'll pretend okay yeah whatever
whatever is there even
Listen, have you been, oh my gosh, you've been practicing,
right, for your concert?
Yeah, mm-hmm.
I just practiced like, yeah, I just practiced yesterday.
Okay, so thing is that now I'm in Thailand because I need to
practice with my band member.
And actually yesterday, technically 10 hours ago, because I
haven't slept yet.
We, that was like, you know, we only practiced through
online.
but it was our first practice on offline on like live
together type deal right yeah on live together and i was
pretty satisfied with this hello keep holding keep holding
the line let me know when we're back i was gonna i was gonna
i was i was oh we're back we're back we're back anyway sorry
You saw I was gonna be super emotional and then I blue
screen They're gonna let their heart out Then I blue screen
I was just speaking all by my own Just being emotional no
one's listening Not even Doki's listening I was speaking
just all by my own I'm in They're like what were you
satisfied with?
You ended on the cliffhanger you saw What were you satisfied
with?
It would be so funny if I blue screen again I'm right where
you say I was super emotional
Oh my god What were you satisfied with You son what was it I
don't want to talk about it again Oh we'll never know We'll
never know it's one of One of the greatest secrets out there
that you know i don't need i don't have to be understood by
others you know i'm just gonna hold it this secret just
belongs to me don't touch it don't hurt me don't hurt me if
you want to know i don't fucking care i don't care you were
so emotional because you were playing with your band for the
first time yeah for the concert member my band member
finally having me back on stage We have been fighting for
this fucking two years and we're finally able to see each
other on stage You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah The blue stream won't
silence you That was a so emotional story That was like, I
was like, you know Before I become vTuber I made a like a
really really big fight with my band members Then we were
not like, you know, we kind of stopped playing together and
I had strong performance anxiety as well you know yeah now
now we're we're back on stage together yeah uh war tour yeah
guys world tour everybody I was talking about this all alone
yeah world tour war tour it means a lot so you know again
thank you for you know being my first guest okay yeah that's
me i'm gonna be there in hong kong august 4th guys for the
two men live yeah moment live there's two of us no no
there's two of us i know how to count you son doesn't know
how to count you son doesn't know how to count it's clearly
one and two i don't i don't equals to usaw why do i have to
мы why i am actually a musician i don't care the numbers
because i'm a musician i'm living with my own sent you know
that's true that's true that's true yeah so many people say
like you know whenever i say something is there any
scientific proof a scientific uh statement or something i
don't have to do that i don't owe doing that i am
responsible for doing that because i'm just a musician
exactly speak your truth you saw speaking
Release me I'm super excited I'm super excited To do this
concert with you son Really looking forward to Jaguins Being
there And yeah, we're looking forward to it Yeah Is there
anything else you want to say before we call it for today
Check my music video Always check You saw his music video
guys The new music video is out.
Villain, covered.
And I hope you guys are going to like it.
All right.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
Guys, we hope you enjoyed today's lesson.
As always, everybody, say hi.
Enjoy the posture.
Get a bit more around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for us, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.